but i understand sandy don't beat
yourself up about not watching it
um it's hard it's hard to watch the
shows
that don't go well it's easy to watch a
show that goes well and it's a victory
lap but it's watching
those shows that go bad when you really
learn the most
you learn the most from bombing those
are going to be your best lessons
and that recording is the black box
that is your um the
the dna of the murder of the crime scene
is that recording so you can go back and
see
where you went wrong where you messed up
what you said you may have
stumbled across some words you didn't
even realize you stumbled across
because you'll say things on stage you
don't even realize good and bad
sometimes so it's always important to
record your sets and review your sets
and refine your sets it's a whole
process
you write you perform you record
you refine repeat over and over and over
again
that is the creative process of stand up
and there's no way around the work
ted alex sandro said on this show you'll
never regret working harder
jeff foxworthy saying the same things on
our q a with him
about the work that goes into stand-up
comedy but you know what we're doing
here at hot breath
we're creating the next generation of
great comics and that comes with
having the habits of great comics which
is writing daily like we do in the right
tin club
which is scheduling shows performing
whether on
zoom or in live person recording those
sets and then reviewing them and then
refining your material
taking them to the writers rooms we have
in this group it's all part of that
process
and we're here for you as well that's
why this community is so valuable
because there's a supportive community
around we can celebrate our victories
and also
overcome our struggles that much more
but it all starts with recording and
reviewing those sets
and what helps me too is
as soon as i perform on my way home or
my on my way to the next show
i'm listening immediately i know if i
don't do it then i'm most likely not
going to do it that's what my brain is
the freshest
that's when my brain is still in comedy
mode so i listen to it immediately after
whether it's on the way home
or whether it's um on the next show
but i just get it over it i just rip the
band-aid off and it's
it's part of it but it's a necessary
evil
in this comedy game you gotta review
those sets
[Music]